[Musique]
c'est l'un des joyaux du québec
14 km de beauté de nature et de
villégiature
mais le lac massawippi est menacée
sous sa surface un monstre road
la bête qui fait trembler les riverains
et les écologistes c'est elle
la moule zébrée
[Musique]
les scientifiques et des plongeurs venus
d'aussi loin que baie-comeau ou la
californie tente de l'éradiquer ils
veulent sauver le lac massawippi avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard si on échappe le
lac massawippi c'est les cantons de
l'est ce qu'on échappe au complet
[Musique]
nous sommes le 2 juin ce matin l'eau du
lac massawippi est à 14 degrés celsius
cela m'a refroidi pas les ardeurs d'une
équipe de plongeurs
leur mission repérer les mots et brille
sous l'eau et les arracher une par une
si on fait rien il ya un désastre c'est
clair si on fait quelque chose on a une
chance et on ne peut pas se permettre de
ne rien faire connaissant les impacts
économiques et écologiques
la moule zébrée est une espèce exotique
envahissante capable de pondre un
million deux par année
ce petit mollusque est originaire de la
mer noire et de la mer caspienne
il est arrivé en amérique du nord à la
fin des années 80 dans les eaux de
ballast de navires
il s'est rapidement propagé dans les
grands lacs et le fleuve saint-laurent
plus la rivière richelieu
partout sur son chemin l'envahisseur
s'accroche aux surfaces dures comme les
coques des bateaux il tapisse les quais
et colmatent les prises d'eau potable il
bouleverse les écosystèmes aquatiques
[Musique]
en amérique du nord des biologistes
mènent une lutte acharnée pour empêcher
l'ennemi conquérir de nouveaux
territoires
mais le mot luce a fini par déjouer la
résistance en 2018 le plongeur de nîmes
on joue à trouver les premières moules
zébrées dans le lac memphrémagog c'est l
alerte maximale parce que lé terrain je
disais à dix kilomètres de celle
[Musique]
michèle gérin dirigé jusqu'à tout
récemment l'organisme plus massawippi
elle fait des pieds et des mains pour
protéger son lac
en 2018 elle appelle la biologiste
aquatique qu isabelle picard spécialiste
de la moule zébrée au québec les deux
femmes passent à l'action
elle exige des plaisanciers qui lavent
leurs embarcations pour éviter de
propager les moules d'un lac à l'autre
elle installe aussi des collecteurs au
bout des quais
si des moules zébrées sont présentes
dans le lac elles viendront s'est fixé
il n'y a pas place à l'erreur le lac
massawippi est particulièrement
vulnérable à la moule zébrée beaucoup
plus que le lac memphrémagog qui est en
train de perdre la bataille
pour comprendre que la moule zébrée à la
base d'un taux de calcium minimale pour
être capable de refaire sa coke et puis
ici on est vraiment dans le maximum dans
l'optimum autres mardi
le 15 octobre 2021 va rester gravé dans
la mémoire de michel giret
ce jour là des plongeurs détecte
premières moules zébrées au lac
massawippi
cette fois c'est la guerre
michèle gérin appelle les gouvernements
en renfort
l'automne dernier quand plus massot et
puis elles ont appelé pions comme fait
ça y est se termine c'était un peu comme
un état de choc et ensuite bye faut
aller voir ce qui se passe
annick drouin et biologiste aquatique
pour le ministère de la faune
une fois alertée par michèle gérin son
premier réflexe est de faire un
inventaire
elle veut savoir exactement où se
trouvent les moules zébrées quels sont
leur densité et leur stade de
développement
il ya peut-être encore une chance de
sauver lac
et moi j'ai fait quelques uns quelques
appels aquarium du québec dans nos
partenaires qu'on connaisse et puis tout
le monde était très mobilisé à venir
mettre du temps à l'automne tard dans
l'automne
pour tourner face cet inventaire le
faire citer d'autres situations le les
plongeurs du biodôme de montréal se
joignent aussi à l'effort on a plongé
jusqu'au 17 décembre
et je vous sens bien d'être là nice
restait noël le pion plonge encore et on
était revenu dans lac il y avait encore
de la glace 20 avril
les résultats de l'inventaire apporte
deux bonnes nouvelles la première c'est
que les moules ne se sont pas encore
propagée à la grandeur du lac elles sont
concentrées dans la portion nord
prennent leur patrie
la deuxième c'est que les moules n'ont
pas eu le temps de se reproduire
c'étaient des jeunes veulent donc des
moules qui avait été épandue pendant
l'été et s'était fixé sur le sol ou
prendre l'année de mes 21 ans et avec la
taille des moules
[Musique]
les scientifiques vont maintenant tenter
le tout pour le tout essayé d'enlever
les moules une à une avant la saison de
reproduction
à chaque mois aux abricots on enlève
présent pas que c'est une mosaïque soir
prend du repos donc c'est une centaine
un millier de moins de mots et bray cet
automne
[Musique]
les moules zébrées débutent leur cycle
de reproduction au début de l'été les
mâles et les femelles relâche leurs
semences dans l'eau les larves issus de
la fécondation dérive pendant deux
semaines avant de se fixer et se
transformer en moule juvénile
dans des conditions optimales comme
celle du lac massawippi on peut compter
jusqu'à dix mille moules par mètres
carrés sur les quais où les prises d'eau
une seule - et bray
après deux litres d'eau par jour elle
retient les nutriments essentiels à sa
croissance et ne laisse rien que pour
les autres espèces
tellement que ce qui est créé c'est un
désert écologique en filtrant un litre
d'eau par jour elle augmente aussi la
clarté de l'eau ça peut faire des
blomdahl beaucoup plus de végétation
aquatique parce que la lumière va
pénétrer plus au bout de trois à cinq
ans la moule zébrée meurent
les coquilles tranchante s'accumulent
sur les plages qu'il faut parfois faire
lui
à ce jour un seul lac a réussi à
éradiquer la moule zébrée le lac george
aux états unis il faut dire que son taux
de calcium n'était pas très favorable à
la propagation de la moule zébrée
ou lac massawippi le combat sera
beaucoup plus difficile la pression est
forte sur les épaules des plongeurs pour
lever des roches parce qu'ils peuvent
être anti des roches oculaires les
branches aussi carrière qui lui fait
crisser de la patience c'est coûte très
cher la moule très cher la moule parce
que j'ai des plongeurs de la gaspésie
des escoumes 1,2 g des plongeurs de
québec de montréal d'ottawa viol ils
viennent de partout folie loger il faut
les nourrir bien ce bien entendu
alexander frei est venue de la
californie pour donner un coup de main
aux plongeurs
ce professeur à l'université de la
californie à davis et experts en
modélisation des courants
j'ai grandi ici
ma famille vient de north hatley
dans le lac de son enfance il a installé
différents instruments certains mesurent
la température de l'eau d'autres la
salinité ou la concentration en oxygène
dissous
avec ces données elle exhale de foirest
est en train de construire un modèle
numérique
il prédit vers quelle zone du lac les
lames risques de dérives et lorsqu'elles
seront relâchés
les plongeurs ça coûte cher difco en
plus c'est difficile de travailler sous
l'eau
notre modèle va permettre d'optimiser
les ressources en pointant où il faut
concentrer les efforts
1 et drouin elle utilise un outil
beaucoup plus finement terre un cadre de
plastique des plongeurs le pose au fond
du lac et mesure la concentration de
moules zébrées qui s'y trouvent
il compte aussi les autres espèces à
l'intérieur du quadra
la biologiste veut savoir à partir de
quel seuil concentration de mauls et
bray menacent les autres espèces
elle espère protégée entre autres le
touladi un poisson emblématique du lac
massawippi
en connaissant bien les seuil auquel
amusé brille un peu d'impact mais on
prendra des stratégies de
d'atténuation ou des frayeurs dont avec
nous retrait d'autres d'autres formules
de gestion pour maintenir les frayeurs
de tous les dix actifs
la guerre s'annonce longue il faut
continuer à sensibiliser les riverains
et serrer la vis quant au lavage des
embarcations site a été avec ta planche
comparé dans le born dans le fleuve au
sternum mai
nemo abri minuscule surtout si tu le
fais en était d'habitude sont vraiment
très petit indétectable la grosseur
d'une tête d'apple facture les verts au
pot je transporte ont pas de leur bord
du site seulement à l'eau et voilà bingo
tiennent en introduire
on veut aussi former des citoyens pour
leur apprendre à plonger reconnaître les
moules zébrées et à les enlever
si on n'arrive pas à éradiquer la moule
zébrée on espère au moins retarder ses
impacts et limiter les dégâts
on espère aussi que les leçons apprises
aideront à protéger d'autres lacs du
québec
si il ya des chances qu'on décontamine
autant 0 ailleurs je serais extrêmement
fier même si j'ai perdu la partie ici je
reste extrêmement fier de sa soeur maya
pour sauf si on le fait
il
[Musique]